[Music]
where my low brother Lucas was born my
parents would think that he wouldn't
walk or talk and the doctors even said
he might not make it to his tenth
birthday but today a few months away
from his tenth birthday we're doing our
15th triathlon together
my name is Noah Aldridge and this is my
brother Lucas Aldridge I guess I'm
talking Noah is 11 and Lucas is 9 and
Lucas was born with a rare genetic
neurologic condition called listen
subtly he's unable to walk unable to
talk he's unable to feed himself but
despite all of his challenges the
happiest little boy that you ever meet
about four years ago our boys started
doing triathlons together in most cases
that wouldn't be a big deal a lot of
kids do triathlons but there's something
very special about the way our boys do
triathlons I pull Lucas in a raft
pressroom ocean then I pull him in a
bike cart during their bike and I push
him in a running cart during the run I
wanted to do this because Lucas can't do
things like weekend he can't really play
sport so this is something we could do
together currently we're training for
our 15th try on which is this weekend
before the race I always feel nervous I
don't think I'll ever get over that I
just don't want to hurt Lucas I don't
care if I win the race he just has to be
okay
[Music]
before the race Lukas gets serious and
he gets his race face on and they're
ready to compete they swim around 200
yards then they transition to a bike
they'll go usually about three to five
miles and then they'll run about a mile
NOAA's strong physically an especially
mentally because he's truly only doing
these races for his brother sometimes I
feel like that Scot be over soon right
but I just hear Lucas that's how he says
go faster
[Applause]
every day is precious with that little
boy I try to soak in the experience
because we don't know how long the boys
will be able to triathlons together any
one of them could be their last what
these boys accomplish gives me immense
sense of pride knowing Lucas for an
inspiration people see these two young
boys and that gives them hope and it
gives them encouragement to go out and
tackle life challenges
[Music]
I'm not sick when I run like I'm really
I'm just so normal
you wouldn't think someone who goes
unconscious like 14 times a day runs
like you just wouldn't put it that way
[Music]
my name is Katie cook I'm 20 years old I
live in Dublin Ireland and I love
running I was dying
there's four two types of epilepsy -
nine years old a one of which which is
frontal lobe epilepsy so at the moment I
have 14 seizures in the 24-hour period
they used to be 1617 so we're common
died sadly which is whoo I was getting
really bad dizziness from my medicine -
and into the hospital they loaded me
which is a term for epileptics when
you're going on like a new medicine and
I didn't wake up until six days later I
was a mobile for the goths up two years
I moved from being in a wheelchair to
being in the same her frame what I
gradually started getting back into
running it kinda gave me this newfound
energy I don't know why I put on my
ready boots and started running I feel
like it's so cliched but you kind of
feel like on top of the world that you
could do anything like I don't feel sick
anymore
until I have a seizure of I don't like
Damas you know it's amazing feeling like
all the endorphins like pulsing here
your body on it's great like I like it's
honestly like amazing I train alone for
most Myron's like during the week
however I do have a pal for my races
like official races which is dr. Colin
Doherty
[Music]
so I have two roles so first of all I'm
her doctor
the other role I play which is to be her
partner in running and my job is to make
sure that when katie has a seizure if
she's running that nobody cards her off
the course no seizure so before I knew
Katie she would run races and if they
were in public people would you know
quite reasonably insists that she be
carried off the course which to her
displeasure so my job is to say no you
know that I am her doctor and that she's
fine that she'll recover and then she
gets up and she runs I don't let
anything really get in the way of living
like at all I just don't think it's the
way to go I suppose yeah I don't I don't
let that burlap sea get in the way at
all
[Music]
you
we didn't really have any fast actors
from Texas until he came along like I
can't really believe my eyes
like I was in shock his hands like they
were always moving and it was like there
was no like thinking about where to put
it it was just like a non-stop just like
he's off the charts he's like as fast as
a lightning bolt
[Music]
my name is Kru Griffith and I'm the
fastest cup sector in the state of Texas
my goal is to be the fastest cup sucker
in the whole entire world when I first
saw tray begin cups tacky I was thrilled
kids on the spectrum are always very
passionate and very intense on what
their fixation is and he just shined I
mean you could see that he was in his
element he was comfortable he was alive
and he was just doing his thing
trade took it to a completely different
level he was doing it systematically
instead of just kind of for fun and it
was all about getting that next best
time what Trey does in five or six
seconds takes me 10 or 12 13 seconds
we've learned not to ever discount what
he says he's going to do Sport Stacking
is using a set of 12 plastic cups and
you stack them in a very specific
sequence of pyramids and you are racing
yourself and you're racing a timer it's
a sport that you don't have to be tall
you don't have to necessarily be able to
run quickly as long as you've got the 12
cups you've got Matt and you've got a
timer you can stack
to me it's just mind-boggling to see
these Dockers like trade his friends and
you can tell they're not even looking at
the cups that they're stacking it is all
muscle memory
I mean it's so fast when they get to
this level that the naked eye cannot see
it all when I found out that I was
having a boy of course I thought about
when I was a boy and playing catch with
my dad in the backyard and he flashed
forward you know thinking about those
types of things with your kid out but
when Trey found stacking it's like okay
cool
here is a sport that he's into and it's
got speed I've always loved sports with
speed and it's got rhythms which make
him happy and I realized what a better
way to bond with my child than to learn
how to stock myself I get to stand next
to my son who's one of the fastest in
the world and stack with him and be a
part of something special watching the
two of them stacked together are
probably some of the best moments I've
ever had our motto has always been the
family that stacks together stays
together and we'd go to these
tournaments together we traveled
together we've made friends all over the
country all over the world I mean it's
definitely enriched our lives
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay oh there's some base hip-hop allows
you to be the voice for the voices
when I met Isaiah I didn't know what to
expect once had an opportunity to
communicate with them I was like now he
can he can talk he can talk he has no
problem talking let's be ground how he
wanted in the song when I think of
Isaiah as an artist or more so feel that
he's a poet he's writing poetry he's
talking about his experiences I don't
care what people think of me
Friday honored that they carry me jump
going but I'd let myself like I'd like
you to my family first records that
Isaiah I did was oxygen to fly he wrote
it always the voice it's a challenge to
be someone else's voice but Isaiah has
so many things that he wants to say we
find a way to make it work
haha yeah yeah okay wouldn't it next
with you we could work on the second
verse for I worked with Isaiah I had a
heavy presence in the local scene as far
as rap music as well there's some
community work all right we're gonna
take it from the top okay we were able
to come together and kind of amplify our
message and that's just that you
shouldn't stand to the side and do
nothing if you're fully capable of doing
something I brought out a special guest
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
in a different mall candy on the road
had to do some different things with the
family all from the typical
[Music]
you
[Music]